[Applaudissements]
je consacre ma vie à l'océan et je le
consacre avec une fondation tara océans
30 une équipe de 35 personnes
formidables des chercheurs une centaine
plus d'une centaine à bord du bateau
régulièrement et le bateau tara qui est
en ce moment au sud de l'atlantique par
40 degrés sud dans les quarantièmes
rugissants au moins on est tous dans la
salle
alors l'océan on entend beaucoup parler
ajouté entre l'océan se réchauffe
l'océan
s'acidifient père de l'oxygène il est
surpêché
il ya des gros enjeux et quand on passe
notre temps et notre vie sans la mer et
avec à étudier cet océan avec la
recherche avec les données on peut
mesurer
il faut s'accrocher
et souvent on me demande des romains
mais comment tu arrives à être toujours
optimiste en l'avenir
c'est une bonne question
alors je me suis beaucoup posé la
question
et
j'ai parfois j'ai cru que c'était une
analyse t qui sape qui disait pas son
nom cet optimisme en l'avenir et puis
j'ai cherché dans mes racines un peu à
force et je vais raconter une histoire
un peu pour vous expliquer de là où ça
vient pour moi en tout cas j'ai grandi à
la montagne - de la mer j'habitais dans
les alpages
de entre 0 et 10 ans
ma mère avait décidé de mettre en
application post 68 elle évalue et des
chèvres et vendait du fromage de chèvre
et des oeufs à la montagne et j'ai
longtemps compris après que sont le truc
le balcon de la du chalet il y avait des
cannabis qui poussait
bref et n'empêche que j'ai vécu là avec
ma soeur et ma mère et on a déjà les
l'école ans qui tous les matins d'hiver
donc la v6 en master avait 8 ans et nous
et ailleurs à l'école tout le monde et
on partait tous les deux ma soeur et moi
est le cartable sur le dos la nuit dans
ce matin bleu de la montagne je pense
que vous connaissez
par moins 10 ma mère est laissé partir
on a fait ça pendant trois hivers
et jamais rien s'est passé on a toujours
réussi à arriver à l'école à l'heure et
c'est quelque chose cet optimisme là je
pense que je tiens cette histoire là en
tout cas c'est que je n'explique pas
tout cas je suis très optimiste et je
veux aussi vous vous dire vous dire
pourquoi
donc j'ai toujours été élevé près de la
nature ce soir près de la mer par la
montagne et c'est naturellement qu'il ya
quand j'avais 28 ans après avoir fait
beaucoup de bateaux dans ma vie j'ai
rejoint l' aventure tard à ce faux
nation tara océans et est depuis 20 ans
j'ai 19 ans maintenant je m'en occupe
avec grand plaisir et au début ce
n'était pas un projet par leur
engagement
c'est un projet de bateau sur la mer
s'intéresser et puis
j'ai quand même une énergie john je
donne beaucoup mais ce projet tous les
jours
et je le suis il ma femme m'a souvent
demandé mais tout vient cette énergie
que tu déploies pour ce truc pour cet
océan
et
et en fait quand ma femme est tombée
enceinte de ma première fille de ma
fille fleur
j'ai commencé ce n'est pas comme avec
tara ont commencé à s'intéresser la
biologie marine aux océans un monde
inconnu et pendant neuf mois j'ai pu
préparer une expédition avec tous les
scientifiques et j'ai pris conscience de
notre ignorance à tous pour cette hausse
est en
commun et puis là neuf mois ont passé ma
fille débarque dans la vie et deux mois
avant le début l'expédition d'une
expulsion de quatre ans et puis
un mois plus tard je me suis mis à
penser le futur non plus à mon avis à
moi de disons 30 ou 40 ans dans le futur
mais à sa vie à elle finalement ma vie
allait continuer dans sa vie et
finalement mon futur à moi devenait plus
2040 2050 et 2100
et j'ai été frappé par
le côté tragique de
deux ça parce que si on ne fait rien
effectivement on est au va au devant de
tragédie c'est sûr et c'est ces deux là
je pense le tir cette énergie 2,2
parfois malsaine pour défendre la cause
de l'océan et pour défendre pour
défendre défendre la mère
alors sur l'océan vous connaissez tous
les rosstat de la mer ne resta de la mer
c'est c'est les baleines les dauphins
les poissons qu'on aime beaucoup après
qu'on apprécie beaucoup manger
c'est les beaux coquillages chili bon ça
c'est un dixième de la biomasse des
océans c'est un dixième de ce qu'il vit
dans l'eau
le neuf dixièmes qui reste c'est
invisible s'appelle moi j'appelle ça le
peuple de visible de l'océan
et ce truc j'ai découvert ça avec tara
je veux partager un peu ce que c'est que
ce truc il ya des virus ou connaissent
bien les russes maintenant ça c'est bon
il ya des bactéries mais dix-huit jeunes
à 10 milliards par litre d'eau de mer
devant la baule des milliards par litre
d'eau de mer il ya des bactéries des
millions par litre d'eau il ya des micro
algues qui font la façade photosynthèse
il ya des insectes qui viennent manger
ça dans la mer et qui sont mangés par
les poissons est ce ce monde là dont on
ne connaît pas grand chose et pour
laquelle tara est connu aujourd'hui dans
le monde entier
et interagit il est affecté les virus
attaque qui régule ce pas que mauvais
ils sont indispensables si pour pour
notre système ils sont tout ça et
finalement à remplir un rôle incroyable
ce micro monde
produit de moitié de l'oxygène qui
produit chaque jour sur terre stocks un
tiers du co2 planétaire
propre arrive à transformer l'énergie
solaire et les nutriments de la mer en
matière organique manger par la chaîne
alimentaire et finalement dégustés par
nous tous
ce monde là est incroyable et en paix
rhdp à l'interaction et ce monde-là très
important tous les quinze jours tous les
quelques jours se multiplient se
réplique donc la vitesse d'évolution
est le garant d'une résilience très
importante de l'océan
parce que ça change tout le temps ça
s'adapte tout le temps mais ça c'est un
message que vous donnez pas ce qu'on
voit très bien dans plein d'endroits
dans le monde dès qu'on arrive à lâcher
une pression sur une zone de la mer très
vite en deux trois ans ce qui est très
vite l'écosystème repart comme si
s'était rien passé on avait rien à faire
il ya une chose qu'on a découvert avec
ce projet tara
aussi dans les données dans l'est les
recherches qui ont été publiés dans les
découvertes c'est que la moitié
quasiment 2 notre micro bioman où
nos bactéries vous savez on a beaucoup
de l'écosystème dans notre corps qui
font quelque chose pour nous sinon la
moitié de ce qu'on a dans le ventre on
le retrouve dans l'océan c'est les mêmes
bactéries
est donc cet océan qu état critique cet
écosystème microscopique ce petit peuple
invisible
indispensable pour les grands équilibres
de la planète co2 oxygène protéines et
encore d'autres choses
finalement c'est même temps dans notre
intestin et qui tous les jours pour
notre bien-être nous aident à digérer ce
qu'on affronte ce qu'on mange et le
transformer pour le mettre à disposition
notre corps de nos cellules
de toute notre bien-être en fait
c'est la même chose ces mêmes bactéries
côte mandingue ça m'a frappé cette
découverte
est donc on va bien
j'ai parlé des pressions au début de mon
intervention on voit bien que
notre écosystème aussi des résidents
dans notre destin quand on prend une
cuite
on met un peu le genre semble 100 m on
s'en remet quand on mange un truc pas
très bon je vous explique pas les
conséquences mais ils on le voit
mais il se remet il est résilient aussi
cet écosystème leur
ceux là même que la mère et vous
comprenez aussi du coup que quand on
mange du plastique on ne digère pas
quand on avale de l'huile du pétrole ont
le digère pas je ne pensais pas le faire
quand on a va des produits chimiques en
général qui sont pas naturels on ne
digère pas eh ben la merde c'est pareil
c'est les mêmes organismes locaux sommet
du bassin dans la mer quand on chauffe
trop la même aussi comme notre
température corporelle
ça marche plus
et donc
l'enjeu aujourd'hui dont on parle tous
c'est comment on arrive à stopper cette
pression pour que cet océan rouge
regagne soit résilient puisse rebondir
finalement
et nous faire bénéficier pour le futur
pour le long terme de ce centre c'est
bien de son bien de tous ces bienfaits
pardon
donc c'est la transition qui est en
cours qu'on doit faire la transition
plastique la transition écologique en
général la tradition sociale la
transition vers le futur en fait
le défi que ça représente
et il faut pas attendre vous voyez bien
des politiques pour nous emmener la
transition il faut la faire nous mêmes
cette transition dans notre vie dans
notre job dans notre famille aussi
etc je suis venu ici à la baule aussi
pour parler aux générations qui ont qui
font leurs études qui ont 20 ans vous
êtes les héros de ma fille et de mon
fils nemo que j'appelais mon fils nemo
c'est profond
jules verne est parmi nous
et finalement vous êtes les héros de ma
fille de 12 ans parce qu'elle regarde
toujours les plus grands elle écoute les
plus grands airs hier comment ils se
sentent aussi les plus grands
il est le héros et nous on essaie d'un
peu d'être vos héros on a un peu de mal
on part de loin il n'empêche que ce que
je voulais vous dire c'est que vous avez
le pouvoir vous qui êtes en fin d'études
en train de choisir la vie vous allez
mener
vers quelle entreprise de l'aller celle
ci plutôt qu'une autre ce secteur plutôt
qu'un autre
vous avez le choix
vous vous rendez pas compte à quel point
avez le choix
ma femme est drh directrice des
ressources humaines d'entreprises et
quand on lui pose la question qu'est ce
que vous faites vous votre entreprise
pour pour la société salants merde
ça
elle a du mal à répondre elle voit bien
que c'est un sujet important et donc
aujourd'hui le pouvoir de changer le
pouvoir cette transition il est dans les
mains de la génération qui arrive parce
que le changement qu'on a besoin c'est
un changement systémique
donc faut jamais croire il faut pas être
anxieux de ce qui va se passer soit vous
avez le choix de dire moi je préfère
bosser dans cette industrie là cette
technologie la ccl remis cela parce que
je me retrouve pas ce qu'il ya du sens
parce qu'il ya de l'impact positif pour
le futur parce qu'on fait ça mieux que
je faisais avant sans avoir de jugement
par rapport au passé
ta message que je voulais vous vous
portez ce et c'est là que
tout ce qui se passe dans la mer
tous les enjeux de la mer température
plastique
surpêche
surconsommation
pollutions diverses des fleuves par les
fleuves c'est un tout ce qui se passe
dans la mer au niveau de l'écosystème et
de la p2 du stress ou les écosystèmes ça
se traite à terre
les enjeux sont à terre
dans l'entreprise qui doit changer
certaines change puisque dit que
d'autres il faut encourager et quand
vous tous au delà des étudiants qui ont
sur leurs chais travail on achète on a
un pouvoir dément sur le futur
et il faut jamais l'oublier
alors voilà on a aujourd'hui dans
l'océan ont des problèmes moi j'ai plus
envie de les prendre comme des défis
quand on prend un problème comme un défi
d'un seul coup ça devient un truc génial
à vivre
c'est pas un problème à résoudre c'est
un défi à relever
et quand on a des problèmes dans la vie
il faut toujours être muette du côté de
la solution du problème ça rend très
heureux pour toute la vie merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]